[Music]
now
oh no no no no he would no no he would
no no talk about it I think is the last
time I'm gonna talk about it
[Music]
Oh Oh it was all a dream it was just a
dream that's just time for my coffee got
my coffee and let's just let's just see
what's going on just see what's going on
today
go right here see what's happening
strike and skyrocketing popularity
because of their initial laser focus on
the developer experience setting up in
making payments stripe was even
initially known as slash dad's flash
payments they spent extra time building
the right SDKs for each language
platform and building beautiful
documentation okay welcome back to fake
guru this is do you see that I'm getting
more disheveled the more I make these
videos these Suraj videos that's because
I just it just doesn't stop you guys it
doesn't stop I wanted to stop the Suraj
talk the last video but more stuff
happened that has to be discussed this
won't be a ten minute video it's gonna
be short video let me just explain it
real quick okay this is pretty it's not
that hard to understand all right
October 11th Suraj makes a livestream
saying hey guys I can I contribute
academia tube that it out with this
great paper because I recently published
a paper called it neural qubits October
13th he gets called out on it and
actually apologizes for it insist luck
basically I'm done with plagiarism
I'm over it I won't plagiarize anymore I
need to slow down and really think about
the stuff that I'm contributing to the
world
October 16th he puts out this video
called top 5 developer tools 2019 here's
what that looks like hello world it's
Suraj and it seems like a new tool for
developers is released every day the
only problem is he plagiarized his video
right after he got called out and
apologized for plagiarizing this time he
plagiarizes the video script from a
variety of random sources and cobbles it
together and tries to change them the
words but it's so obvious that it's
straight from these articles so we're
gonna go through them this one is a
TechCrunch write-up on AP is another
behemoth valued at over 22 billion
dollars today stripe skyrocketed in
popularity because of their initial
laser focus on the developer experience
setting
making payments stripe was even
initially known as /dance flash payments
they spent extra time building the right
SDKs for each language platform and
building beautiful documentation this
one is a doc you source right up on
Hacker News can also progressively
enhance it through regular JavaScript
and generates clean static output that
we can manually introspect here's one
from Nordic api's five examples of
excellent API documentation and why we
think so too
here we go instead of using a standard
two panel design it gets you to choose
your programming language of choice
first and then provides tailored
documentation for that language so guys
I'm not gonna make this longer than it
has to be yeah yeah three days after
admitting that he plagiarized an
academic paper he plagiarized as part of
his script right off ripping right off
some popular articles and just throwing
them on video as his own ideas so that's
all make your own conclusions let this
be hopefully I'm not gonna say never
anyway I will never say never anymore
but let hopefully this will be the last
fit blast last last video I'm going back
to bed you guys have a wonderful day
[Music]
[Music]
Sakura
the car
[Music]